powerful winter storm is barreling
across the Northeast bringing frigid
temperatures and blizzard conditions
that's never fun strong winds and heavy
snow lowered visibility to nearly zero
in parts of upstate New York yesterday
and this weekend the temperatures could
plummet as much as 15 degrees below
average in some areas that is cold
people Don de leurs in Adams New York
that's about an hour north of Syracuse
Don what are conditions like there you
got your long underwear on if you can
see it is right over here
this is something that meteorologists
are pulling a fire hose in effect where
all of this snow is being pumped off of
Lake Ontario with very high winds and it
could end up dumping three to four feet
in this area you could barely see
through the blustery snow as it barreled
through upstate New York plows struggled
to get the upper hand with snow piling
up almost as quickly as it was clear
waves slammed the shore of Lake Ontario
where a warmer winter has left most of
the Great Lakes ice-free those
conditions have combined with this
storms cold dry air to create heavy
winds and snow but Jerry Hudson of Adams
New York said it's business as usual
treacherous whiteouts windblown ships
winter again here in upstate New York
the New York Department of
Transportation posted this video warning
commuters that the safest place to drive
is behind plows on clear roads but
whiteout conditions still cause
tractor-trailer accidents here and in
Pennsylvania where parts of interstate
90 were briefly closed after two semis
jackknifed the National Weather Service
says that this storm has a long way to
go even for areas outside the reach of
the fire hose they can expect up to an
additional two feet of snow through
Sunday Anthony Don Dahler thank you very
much Don